i think it's clear what happened alec
had the gun in his hand he shot it
helena was killed
this chilling reenactment of alec
baldwin's alleged role in the rush
shooting was played this morning for
reporters the animation was produced by
attorneys for the family of helena
hutchins and shows the actor with the
gun that killed the cinematographer
there are regulations and guidelines in
place today that should prevent
something like this from happening but
they need to be enforced
the video also shows purported text
messages between crew members describing
the rust set as unsafe and alec in his
abc news interview when i cocked the guy
can you see that can you see that can
you see that and she says and then i let
go of the hammer the gun and the gun
goes off
helena's attorney also announced a
wrongful death lawsuit against alec and
the film's producers this doesn't happen
unless people cut costs and engage in
reckless behavior leading to a senseless
tragic death
alec who was in new york today fired
back through his legal team quote any
claim that alec was reckless is entirely
false i don't work as much as i used to
last week he talked about being back to
work on the set of another independent
film i haven't worked since
the accidental death of our
cinematographer helene hutchins
[Music]